j'accueille maintenant pour sa première
télévision en france
naviguant balle
l'aomi bonsoir alpha bonsoir monsieur
alors je vous joins mes amis je vous
regarde dans les yeux parce que vous
avez dit que s'il n'a même pas capable
de vous regarder dans les yeux c'est pas
la peine qu'ils vous regardent
c'est tout à fait vrai je vous regarde
dans les yeux comme ça voilà alors d'air
quand on vous regarde on s'aperçoit que
vous êtes extrêmement jolie et que votre
réputation n'est pas usurpée
votre secret c'est quoi j'ai fait
ensuite mastic tous les matins partir du
bien mais est elle maintenant que j'ai
30 ans j'ai décidé qu'il est temps de
faire ton si vous faites attention vous
mangez plus que vous voulez maintenant
parce qu'il n'est pas vous mangez plus
que je mangeais plus tôt ce que je veux
mais je sais que j'ai payé pour ça si je
me laisseront pas les barbouzes et des
mensurations de rêve évidemment vous
faites un mètre 77 86 61 88 les
connaisseurs apprécieront
le seul problème c'est que vous chaussez
du 40 s'est beaucoup ça quand même pour
une femme et vous posez vous foutez de
combien vous posez pas ce que vous avez
même pas de thèse personne chez vous
vous avez dit que j'ai un personne et
j'ai pas besoin de mentir tout le temps
je pense que ça mais nous les femmes on
sait ce qui a changé quand on se voit
dans le miroir sans avoir tout à fait à
passer sur la pièce deux pièces qu'un
seul alors andré leon talley que moi je
me permettrai pas de parler de votre
physique évidemment mais andre leon
talley qui est un grand journaliste de
mode américain qui a longtemps travaillé
au vogue us a dit en parlant de vous
naomi cambell un fessier si haut si
stable si ferme qu'on pourrait poser une
flûte de champagne dessus est utilisé
comme table à cocktail essayons ce soit
est ce qu'on va nous apporter du centre
et donatella versace a dit de vous vous
étiez la marine monroe noir je ne pense
pas mais c'est vraiment très gentil de
dire ça de moi mais j'aime beaucoup ma
résine
je l'aimé beaucoup vous la trouvez
comment j'aime très belle est intimidé
aussi elle
oui moi aussi je verrai ça et tout net
c'est vous savez c'est un petit peu ma
personnalité bien côté timide un côté
qui n'est pas et quand on en public vous
pas c'est qu'à chaque fois que je suis
mieux par exemple dans les coulisses et
que je vais commencer un show je ne suis
pas nerveuse mais si je suis nerveuse je
pense que c'est bien de ne pas être trop
sûr de soi même parce que vous donnerez
pas le meilleur de vous même donc j'ai
c'est effectivement de donner le
meilleur d'eux mêmes et ça veut dire
être un peu nerveux
alors votre beauté est dû à des origines
très mais les 12es du sang chinois du
sang noir du sang sont blancs aussi donc
ma grand mère elle s'appelait mieux
avant qu'elle ne se mariaient à mon
grand père et mon grand mon
arrière-grand-père des activités
chinoises
c'est un beau mélange et pourtant alors
quand vous étiez à l'école à l'école
d'art à stockwell vos camarades vous
appelez sac d'os alors ça a changé quand
même les sacs de sable et les enfants
tout est très méchant les avec les
autres alors l'époque j'ai commencé par
faire de la danse poussé par votre mère
qui voulait vous soyez une star non non
non elle a sacrifié ses inspirations en
ma faveur mais quand j'avais 13 ans je
lui ai déjà dit à l'époque je voulais
passer à trois ans
c'était déjà en mesure de dire ce que je
voulais absolument elle ne pouvait pas
m'obliger à le devenir il fallait que je
le sentais c'était le cas vous avez ça
en commun avec jeanne moreau et xavier
un bon caractère déjà très affirmée très
jeunes je les sens commun alors à
l'époque vous pensiez pas devenir
mannequin jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un vous
vous découvre vous avez été découvertes
comment un quartier enfin sur ie covent
garden à londres et j'avais 14 ans il
s'était après cole je me baladais cette
dame a été élu c'est une ex mannequin
elle m'a dit j'ai une agence est ce que
vous pouvez venir me voir il y avait ces
filles blondes magnifique avec des
cheveux longs et je me disais mois et
deux ans plus tard ma mère m'a dit
d'accord mais au débit elle voulait me
l'interdire elle disait je ne veux pas
que tu fasses là après deux ans je l' ai
rappelé manni mais je me souviens de
vous et à 16 ans naomi campbell devient
mannequin
vous êtes le premier mannequin noir à
avoir fait la couverture de vogue
évidemment iv iman bowie et grace jones
qui avait ouvert la voie
vous avez été la première à faire la
couverture de vogue et après d'ailleurs
la première à faire la couverture de
time magazine
dix ans dix ans après vous pensez que ça
a évolué vous pensez que c'est plus
facile
dix ans après pour des filles noires de
faire des couvertures de magazines en
amérique où c'est toujours pareil c'est
pire qu'avant
en quelques mois je pense que c'est pire
si vous regardez les magazines présent
de cette année mais vous pouvez encore
être deux et c'est peut-être parce que
je le maintiens vécu ici
défilé avec une personne maintenant j'ai
vu défiler des salaires aux morts j'en
ai vu qu'une année ça et ça change que
c'est vraiment très triste parce que ça
montre que les gens sont très étroits
d'esprit y tu feras pas vers le mieux
donc
alors vous avez connu un énorme succès
vous avez gagné en 1998 15 millions de
francs quand vous dites vous gagner
beaucoup d'argent vous dit d'abord parce
que je suis pas mannequin comme les
autres et deuxièmement il m'arrive de
faire des choses gratuitement
c'est vrai je me fermais et en deviendra
comme ainsi et il n'avait pas d'argent
du tout alors d'être chez dior ils ont
dit on va faire notre propre collection
n'avons pas d'argent j'ai dit ok et j'ai
aussi appelé d'autres filles et j'ai
raison et parce que je crois en la
créativité j'aime beaucoup ce qu'ils
font vous avez fait partie des ce qu'on
a appelé les super modèle d'ipad et à
poney les super modèle c'était quoi les
super modèle marche plus c'est une
espèce de technologie qui est adoptée
par la presse par les médias qu'ils
n'ont pas inventé ça a créé un peu plus
de scandale je sais pas vraiment
pourquoi mais je pense que quand j'ai
offert des fils avait que toutes les
autres mannequins nous sommes tous tout
dans la même situation il est vrai qu'à
l'époque le petit belinda ça suffit
c'est vrai nom c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
il y avait une aube et linda chesaux
translate
belinda non c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
naomi il y avait un groupe de filles
avaient cindy crawford linda evangelista
christy turlington cette année c'est moi
c'est toute une bande de filles
j'ai toujours ensemble sur les podiums
très copines entre vous et ça crée une
bombe peut être pour ça que vous appelez
les super modèle non ce qui était bien
dans ce groupe c'est qu'on était
solidaire en céda on disait alors qu'est
ce que tu penses de ça il y avait
toujours ce va et vient cette relation
très forte ce n'est plus la même chose
mais je pense que on en pourra pas
s'amuser autant mais c'est vraiment des
bons soins alors elton john dit en
parlant de vous quand on voit naomi
campbell sur un podium
on réalise qu'elle mérite vraiment
chaque centime qu'elles gagnent savez
j'avais 15 ans était en fait en train de
mûrir de brandir devant les publics je
faisais tout mais avant tout donc c'est
déjà difficile de faire des erreurs en
tant qu'adolescente ensuite failli le
faire devant tout le monde dans québec
c'est vraiment spécial passé mais on
apprend de ses erreurs
ouais c'est vrai en plus dans le métier
quand on dit non une fois ci un
photographe vous photographiez vous
voulez pas ou si on vous met un micro
comme ça sous le nez voulait pas
répondre on vous traite tout de suite
deux gars c'est vrai que c'est difficile
de se protéger contre cette agression
des médias juste dit non vous êtes une
garce ridicule parce que il faut enfin
l'analyse qui vous reste quelque chose
vous avez été victime de ça vous de
cette espèce de l'agression des médias
comme été victime moi j'avais fait le
choix c'était une fois dans une rue de
rome
j'étais avec
un homme que je connaissais depuis peu
et on intéressait particulièrement les
paparazzi comme on les appelait et on
n'arrêtait pas de nous suivre un jour
j'en ai marre je dis on s'arrête et on
fait les photos ils ont pris les photos
après ça les intéressait pas les
intéresser plus oui c'est la chasse qui
vous intéressent à la voile et le gibier
c'est le moment donné est ce que votre
réputation de capricieuse n'a pas été
lancée par john casablanca quand vous
avez quitté évite pas ce métier la
première fille a quitté vite finalement
je n'étais pas une des favorites
ce monsieur casablancais et je pensais
qu'il serait plutôt fou d'elle que de
moi mais comme j'étais le premier
mannequin acquis à le quitter
je pense qu'il ne savait pas quoi faire
et quoi dire je suis toujours avec elite
j'ai du respect pour gérald mari j'ai
toujours à intimiste et je pense qu'en
fait c'est toujours très très ce que
toutes les personnes qui l'ont aidé à se
construire avec les cayes la purée mais
en fait il les a virés ça je pense que
c'est pas très professionnel et c'est
vraiment très déplacées dont cup je n'ai
rien d'autre à dire sion dual-core très
bien non mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
naomi vous vous donnez du mal être et
scandaleuse à l'époque quand même vous
passez votre temps dans les boîtes de
nuit à boire des coups où tout le monde
se demande si vous avez une culotte vous
soumet c'était possible c'est vrai non
ça va si tu n'es pas qu'un peu
rock'n'roll soûlard c'est vrai j'ai les
internes ont donc qu'est ce qu'on fait
quand on avait un talent mais on veut
aller s'amuser danser avec les copains
vous savez venant de moi ce n'est pas un
reproche parce que moi non plus je n'ai
pas de style dans le coeur je ne peux
pas je devrais pas vous cliquiez
je ne veux pas m'exciter bien mais c'est
vrai que l'on vous a marié un peu comme
jeanne moreau d'ailleurs parce que tous
les hommes qu'on vous a attribué vous
n'avez pas eu obligatoirement non mais y
en a comme un pari on voit on vous a
attribué beaucoup beaucoup d'hommes il y
en a certains en tous les cas si vous
avez eu bravo parce qu'il ya vraiment
des très beaux il ya eu cette histoire
de tentative
on a parlé très actif de suicides au au
canada je sais j'étais vraiment en
colère j'étais cours d'une campagne sur
les vices est donc en train de faire
cette prise vie et c'était bien mais je
dis vous avez un virus une gastro
entérite
je me suis dit mais je peux pas les
hôpitaux qu'est ce que je fais mais en
fait ça aurait été dans un pays normal
vous auriez eu un médecin qui serait
venu à l'hôtel mais comme c'était un
petit peu isolé mais c'est vrai
peut-être vous avez eu cette réputation
de gars peut être parce que vous avez
cherché à vous protéger à construire un
mur autour de vous je pense que quand
une lorsqu'on est jeune on est un peu
sur la défensive
je n'étais pas défensive quand il s'agit
s'agissait de ma vie privée mais
évidemment a fait du fait de la couleur
de ma peau je me défendrai aussi et
maintenant que j'ai 30 ans réalise qu'il
ya d'autres manières de le tenir ce
qu'on veut sans avoir à être aussi
désagréable et
j'essaye ces nouvelles méthodes et ça
marche j'avais marrante parce qu'elle
dit maintenant que j'ai 35 ans 30 ans
maintenant je suis une grande fille
belle jeanne talentueuse et qui est du
succès c'est toujours une gare ce
qu'elle fait c'est vrai on dit toujours
ça défile qui réussit ce match
conditionne madonna on discerne mariah
carey ont dit ça de toutes les filles
c'est vrai vous avez raison absolument
alors maintenant évidemment vous êtes
rentrée l'aomi kambale dans une époque
de rédemption 30 à la france
maintenant elle a fait une thérapie une
thérapie aux usa naomi affine thérapie
pour apprendre à se contrôler elle est
rentrée maintenant dans une vraie
période de rédemption
parce que vous avez des choses dont on
faisait des troubles du comportement
vous aimeriez vous arrivé à l'âge de 28
ans je n'avais pas de pause entre un
comportement mais j'ai simplement a
décidé que je ne voulais pas travailler
j'ai décidé de prendre des vacances
pendant deux mois de partir et ceci n'a
rien à voir avec mannequinat c'était mon
éducation je voulais essayer de
découvrir des choses de ma famille des
choix tout à fait personnel et pour
essayer de faire un peu d'introspection
il faut pouvoir partir il faut pas avoir
de téléphone il faut pas voir la
télévision il ne faut pas voir des
distractions et c'est ce que j'ai fait
et en fait c'est une chose très simple à
faire
et c'est de s'occuper de soi même et
c'est la première fois de ma vie que
j'ai pu effectivement mon cas et
j'espère maintenant d'intégrer ceux ci
dans ma vie quotidienne et pour que pour
avoir une espèce d'épée d'esprit vous
êtes allé dans une clinique aux états
unis vous étiez c'est vrai que c'est il
ya quatre par chambre non site est
unique
c'était en plein désert
vous pouvez partir et c'est vraiment un
choix que vous faites et il est vrai que
il y avait des personnes avec qui il
partageait la chambre elle était
merveilleuse et c'est quelque chose que
je voulais faire faire et personne ne
peut vous forcer à l'introspection
c'est une décision très forte que vous
devez prendre vous même
est-ce que c'est pas quand même une idée
de votre votre amoureux flavio briatore
de vous envoyer là-bas elle met pas du
tout je suis allé voir flavio lui dis-je
c'est ce que je vais faire
perceuse personne qui ait pu me dire
quoi faire et quelqu'un m'avait dit de
le faire je serais parti je ne serai
jamais rester il faut vouloir y aller il
faut dire que flavio briatore est un que
vous le connaissez non non c'était le
bain c'est lui qui s'occupait de
l'écurie benetton de formule 1 ils ont
été deux fois champion du monde avec
chemin schumacher ah oui c'est quelqu'un
de très bien très très bien m'a regardé
et m'a regardé regarder alors si vous
avez choisi ou pas ok c'est le vieux ou
le fret on a nommé m'acheter l'ours mais
à la la je pense que naomi a un homme de
sa vie
ben hammam
je crois je peux vous dire en droit
pouvant d'acheter une autre
[Applaudissements]
à temps
car aucune chance un malaise inside à
l'intérieur on peut dire naomi que c'est
l'homme de votre vie maintenant
flavio on peut dire ça heureux que vous
soyez relation bien alors je vais vous
dire une chose
il a il a 50 ans vous avez 30 ans c'est
très bien non mais que 50 ans peut avoir
30 ans parce que tu es là diffèrent bien
sûr voilà exactement 20
vous avez dit naomi campbell en parlant
des enfants si je doit tomber enceinte
je tomberai enceinte mais je veux pas
non plus faire des enfants parce que
toutes mes collègues en ce moment sont
en train de faire des enfants
j'ai trois amis à l'heure actuelle
qu'ils sont enceintes je peux pas dire
leur nom et je me dire là là à temps
pour chaque personne quand ce sera le
temps le monde bon moment pour moi et
bien voilà je le saurai vous avez pu le
temps de faire vos petits dîners pascal
vous étiez ya pas longtemps hésité à
londres j'ai des petits dîners entre
amis vous dites maintenant je suis
incapable de vous donner le nom d'une
boîte de nuit à new york
vous préférez regarder la télévision est
devenue très sage c'est vrai que vous
avez pas bu une goutte d'alcool depuis
un an
quatorze mois exactement - 14
et vous que
[Applaudissements]
le centre d'intérêt dans la vie naomi à
votre parfum le premier parfum c'est le
premier qui a porté le nom vraiment de
quelqu'un qui s'appelait naomi campbell
vous êtes très impliqué dans la
fabrication pas seulement vous n'êtes
pas seulement l'image du parfum vous
êtes aussi impliqué dans la je participe
aux réunions où on parle même par
exemple du package alors je souhaiterais
rassurez moi vous n'allez pas devenir
comme ivana trump quand même acheté je
suis sous quand on s'attendait à voir le
succès qu'elle allait oui alors naomi en
dehors de votre parfois rejetées
occultait beaucoup de du fonds pour les
enfants de nelson mandela
depuis quatre ans avec l'humain l'ordre
j'ai travaillé avec lui un lot 5 et en
février 2001 j'ai organisé l'atelier
d'un cancer et qu'il est ou est ce soir
l'invité et c'est pour une chose qu'on
peut pas vous forcer à faire et monsieur
mandela est venu dans ma vie quand j'ai
perdu
gianni versace qui était un ami
j'étais vraiment très triste et j'étais
un peu perdu il m'a dit viens ici je dis
non c'est l'afrique du sud s'est
vraiment pas un pays où je veux aller et
il a dit non il faut que tu viennes
parce qu'il faut pas prendre pour tuer
et aider les autres tu es moins de
chance que la grèce et c'est quelque
chose qui est très riche et il c'est un
homme incroyable il ne se plaint jamais
il n'est jamais un rôle à cet homme qui
m'a gardé en prison pendant 25 ans je
sais pas comment y arrive c'est un
humain il est d'une humanité
extraordinaire et il a 82 ans est en
fait ils en fixent 62 et le dalaï lama
s'était engagé auprès du dalaï lama
aussi où j'ai rencontré chewbacca qu'est
ce qu'il advient des trois personnes de
l'euro contre l'allemagne je suis adepte
et je me souviens avoir après quelqu'un
qui est très célèbre
les proches de lui et j'ai dit qu'est ce
que qu'est-ce que d'où je dois donner un
chèque que ce soit il m'a dit dans ses
passes il veut vous raconterez parce
qu'elles pensent qu au travers de voyage
vous pouvez faire passer la parole les
messages ainsi qu'un seul passager
merguez oui c'est trois personnes
également fidel castro y z'ont tu sais
pas trop sacrifié leur vie
il est très malin en communication se
donner la main parce qu'il a pris comme
ça des gens très connus un castrum
sifaoui ya réussi à se glisser dans
l'est est-ce que c'est pas une façon
naomi campbell toutes ces actions vous
mené auprès de mandela auprès du dalaï
lama
c'est pas une façon de racheter un peu
vos excès que j'ai décidée c'est
l'engagement j'avais toujours pas de
révélation particulière de venir ici
simplement c'est parce que je pensais
qu'il fallait que je donne quelque chose
que je rende je sais que j'ai beaucoup
de chance et je suis très reconnaissante
au destin et c'est ma façon de rendre
quelque chose dites quelque chose à quoi
je n'avais pas du tout pensé c'est à
dire 2 s'utiliser soi-même pour essayer
de ferme à faire avancer une cause et
j'aime bien le faire c'est difficile
parce que on en arrive à pleurer quand
vous allez dans les hôpitaux
vous craquez après dix hôpitaux et il ne
faut pas pleurer parce que là les
enfants
oui pense qu'ils sont eux qui vous rend
triste et en fait il faut que vous
contrôliez faut aimer ce que vous calme
y est
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous avez toujours une petite
pierre dans votre dans votre sac
et cette petite pierre vous l'apporté
partout elle vous a inspiré pour la
forme de votre flacon du parfum
c'est un ami qui m'a abordé en disant tu
voyages tellement vous savez ces chinois
qui ont ces petits trucs comme ça qu'ils
mènent a cassé la même chose dont on
peut je sors le pigalle est donc si je
m'assois comme ça je commence à manier
s'était calée et les des gens moins 10
quand on était à faire la bouteille pour
as qu on est serré et pas de faire cette
même forme et c'est ce qu'on a fait
c'est la crise et comme elle est ce que
ça veut dire que vous êtes
superstitieuse jeu les thèmes
effectivement s'il y avait un chat noir
ouacifs allait passer sous une échelle
aussi j'avais un petit grattements dont
fait partie que c'était la fois de la
bonne fortune ouvriers oui un petit peu
quand même
oui je viens ce ton est pas prêt à table
sur harris essart et ça tombe bien on va
faire une interview croyance en la
bouche pendant le signal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais m mettez à l'us open you must
not move du règne de music abonde jean
monnet mais pâtit oms a réinstauré pas
laissé me refaire un
on ne bouge pas pendant des heures
[Musique]
ok merci thank you alors est ce que vous
croyez à la magie noire
non non à la magie blanche
est ce que vous croyez en dieu oui oui
absolument
est ce que vous croyez à l'effet des
crèmes antirides
d'ailleurs je suis dit bon je sais
vaguement bébé
si vous voyez la fidélité oui je crois
vous croyez au père noël pour les
enfants oui est ce que vous croyez au
retour des spice girls
j'aime bien baby spice je trouve qu'elle
est adorable tenue avec qui vous êtes
disputer quand même en poche un nom mais
elle a décidé d'avoir une discussion
d'avoir une petite bataille avec marc
bellemare
moi je ne disputerai jamais avec vous
jamais non à laquelle arrive on sera
toujours amis je me fâche avec vous
parce que quand on va se fâcher avec
avec vous cela
est ce que vous croyez vous allez passer
toute votre vie avec flavio briatore aux
options j'espère bien belinda et vous
bévinda est ce que vous avez trouvé
l'homme de votre vie mais j'ai trouvé
l'homme de ma vie
dallas malgré mes 20 ans et demi vous
voyez j'ai l'homme de ma vie esquivé sur
le plateau mais je ne sais pas vers
était en fait moi je suis ici lui il est
là bas que fait-il
où va-t-il
belga
bravo belinda bon mais jeanne moreau
merci en tous les cas merci à bien
j'étais très heureux de vous avoir et
moi un bon scénario
m
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu